dawn is in Phoenix hey dawn how are you
I'm well how about yourself
better than I deserve what's up good my
husband graduates dental school this
coming May at the same time that our
lease is up he already has a job lined
up right after graduation and the
company provided a letter stating on the
minimum that he would make and I was
wondering should we go ahead and
purchase a home or continue to rent one
or two more years knowing that our rent
will be raised are you if you got
medical school debt don't schools yet oh
yes yeah yeah you should rent until you
get that cleared up okay for the whole
thing the whole amount cleared up before
we purchase a home yep so what's it
going to be making the minimum first
year is 120 and how much student loan
debt does you have Oh 480 good Lord to
be a member you're going to say that
yeah it's a private school yeah yeah
you're wrong you written an apartment
cheap you have a you have a half a
million dollars in debt mm-hmm
you need to be acting like your hair's
on fire because it is I know um so even
if like the rent darling darling you're
four hundred and eighty a thousand
dollars in student loan debt
there's not even if you cheat cheat
cheep-cheep-cheep no life you have to
clean this mess up you're going to spend
50 years screwing with this if you guys
don't really really do just come have no
life completely attack this you are not
a rich dentist wife you are a broke
dentist's wife yes and you got to act
that way this is a mess it's an
unbelievable mess the most ridiculous
mess I've heard this week Wow
oh I'm so sorry you're in this you can
get through it but you can't be running
around buying stuff and figuring out how
it's Oh
okay to buy stuff you're broke you're a
half a million dollars and dad
to be a dentist or Lord Lord Lord Lord
hey guys Rachael Cruz here hope you
enjoyed that video from the Dave Ramsey
show if you want to watch another great
video check out my video three things
you should consider renting right over
here or click the link in the
description below